this
International donors conference
together for the people of turkey and
Syria
which is going to be in this room and
also online
I want to begin with some of the
housekeeping rules
first of all we have translations into
and from English French German Italian
Spanish Arabic and Turkish languages
also please note that the conference is
web streamed
so I welcome also our audiences online
and I would also like to call on the
photographers cameraman and press now to
leave the room so that we can start
Earnest thank you
so dear president the prime minister
ministers ladies and gentlemen
I'm grateful for the response of the
International Community to this goal of
ours
made together with the Swedish
presidency
together with the Turkish authorities
first we want to express our sincere
condolences to the victims of families
and loved ones
and wish
to quick recovery to the wounded we
stand with you during this time of grief
second we want the people of turkey and
Syria to know that you can count on the
unwavering solidarity and support in
these difficult times
we will assist you in the early recovery
relief and reconstruction efforts
following the disastrous earthquakes of
last month
the immediate reaction of the region
Europe and the entire world has been
impressive
in the wake of this unprecedented
catastrophe resources have been
mobilized to rescue
to help and to shelter those in need
but of course our help does not stop
here
it is clear that we will need to do
significantly more
to overcome the human suffering and
alleviate all the damages
and
we as International Community stand
ready
to take our share on trying to help
turkia and Syria to overcome this
tragedy
today's donors conference has the
ambition to take this next step towards
recovery and reconstruction
the damages and the needs are massive if
not unprecedented
and must be tackled urgently
the European commission is ready to do
everything in its power to help
we're ready to participate in building
new houses
schools hospitals and other critical
infrastructure
so that normal life can return to these
regions in Turkey
we will support public services and
businesses to restart
we are equally committed to provide
humanitarian and early recovery
assistance to the millions of syrians
who have suffered the consequences of
the earthquakes in addition to the
suffering of the 15 years-long War
this is the kind of solidarity we are
here to demonstrate today
through this International donors
conference we have the opportunity to
announce our support
help our partners to manage the impact
of this earthquake and build resilience
to Future natural disasters
I'm looking forward to your pledges
and it is now my pleasure to give the
floor to my dear colleague Johan for
sale from Sweden
thank you commissioner excellences
distinguished delegates their colleagues
ladies and gentlemen
it is my pleasure to be here today at
this pledging conference initiated by
the Swedish prime minister
and the president of the European
Commission
and I would like to thank all of you for
attending and in addition to the people
that are present in this room I know
that many people and Civil Society
organizations are following the
conference online
and on behalf of the Swedish presidency
you are all very welcome
the destruction following the earthquake
is enormous
and the consequences for human lives
devastating the economies of the
countries that have been struck will be
affected for a very long period of time
and when we travel to Ankara to prepare
for this conference together with our
Turkish counterparts commissioner
vargeli and I received a warm welcome
but also heartbreaking information about
the suffering and the needs of the
people affected
and in this time of need when disaster
hits it is crucial that the
International Community comes together
and shows Unity it is important for the
people affected but also important for
the multilateral system
I'm looking forward to the pledging
session where the European and broader
International Community will showcase
their support with the people in their
time of need commissioner I hand the
floor back to you
thank you very much Minister and now let
me invite to the stage our president
president from the European Commission
president you have the floor
thank you very much
foreign
excellencies ladies and gentlemen
thank you for joining us today
when the earth started to shake
in turkey and Syria
it was cold
it was dark
and raining
people were sleeping in the warmth of
their homes
when the sky Came Crashing Down
the pain of the loss of life is
inexpressible
more than 40
000 48 000 people dead
thousands still missing
Millions homeless
in minutes cities and communities were
turned to mounds of rubble
and dust
entire families were lost
their bads turned into coffins
when the sun rose that morning
the people of turkey and Syria were in
shock and Mourning
the whole world held its breath
but tens of thousands sprang to action
to rescue and save those who were still
alive beneath the devastation
to heal
and to give shelter to those
who lost everything
thousands volunteers Working Day and
Night in the dust and in the cold
saving hundreds of lives
screaming of Joy whenever they found a
Child Alive under the rubble
the First Responders performed miracles
in the midst of tragedy
they inspired hope
where there is so much pain
this is a story of catastrophic loss
and
it is a story of heroic solidarity among
the people of Turkey
the people of Syria
and your friends around the world
on that morning many rushed to help
the European Union to immediately
activated its civil protection mechanism
hours after the first earthquake
European rescue teams arrived in Turkey
just as a second earthquake almost as
powerful as the first cause even caused
even more death
1652 European rescues
and 111 search docs helped the Local
Heroes
Hungarian firefighters for example
found Selma
a Turkish woman five meters beneath the
collapsed building
where she lay for 47 hours
it was in the middle of the night
when they heard her cries with minus
nine degrees Celsius outside
they got her out alive and sell them A
Story of Survival is one of many
polish and Bulgarian teams found and
saved an entire family of four
and the first survivors of this first
Survivor of French medical team treated
was a three-month pregnant Syrian
refugee
for over 10 days they searched the
rubbles
at gaziantep airport
there were rescued Medical Teams from
all over the world
many were crying
they were exhausted
they hadn't slept for days
I think we owe them an overwhelming
gratitude
today's impressive attendance at this
donors conference testifies to the
international community's strong
response
the whole world mobilized to support the
people of turkey and Syria
because the scale of this strategy is so
large
that no one country or agency alone
could have done anywhere near what we
have done together
six weeks later the scale of the
devastation from the earthquakes is
still being uncovered
and the international mobilization has
not stopped
tents and clothes and food and medical
supplies continue to arrive
yet the needs of the survivors are still
massive
and must be tackled with urgency
the earthquakes affected a region in
Turkey home to 13.5 million people and
an unknown number in Syria
millions are now homeless and living
intense as the winter drags on
we need to sustain our support and help
the survivors not just to survive but to
rebuild their lives
ladies and gentlemen we need to mobilize
for reconstruction
homes and schools and hospitals must be
rebuilt
with the highest standards of seismic
safety
water and sanitation and other critical
infrastructure
must be repaired
public services and businesses need
Capital to restart
so that people can earn a living
we will hear later from the undp a
presentation of the first estimates of
damages
but we already know the challenge is
immense
larger than any one of us alone can
Master but
together we can Master the challenge
and that is why together with the turkey
authorities and the Swedish presidency
of the council
the European commission has organized
this pledging conference
no one can fill the void by left by
those who lost their lives
yet together we can reconstruct and
rebuild
the European Union and its member states
and financial institutions have put
together a strong pledge
I am pleased to announce
that the European commission alone
will support turkey with one billion
Euro for the post-earthquake
reconstruction
we also pledge a further package of 108
million euro
for humanitarian assistance and early
recovery in Syria
on top of this Our member states and the
European financial institutions will
make additional pledges
that comes on top of the 21 million
euros and humanitarian assistance that
we have already mobilized
so I invite all nations and all donors
to contribute
to honor the memory of the lives lost
to honor the heroism of the First
Responders
and to sustain the hope
of the survivors
thank you very much and I now gave the
floor to the prime minister of Sweden
[Applause]
foreign
Excellence is ladies and gentlemen
42 days ago the lives
or millions of people in turkey and
Syria changed completely in just a
matter of seconds
within a few minutes hundreds of
thousands of people lost their homes
their everyday routines their sense of
normalcy and belonging
in the following days it became
painfully clear that hundreds of
thousands of people lost someone they
loved
over 50 000 lives were lost
as a European union and as members of
the International Community we cannot
take away the grief or the pain we
cannot feel the voids from the loved
ones that were lost in the earthquakes
but we can do one thing we can turn our
words of condolences and solidarity into
action that is why we meet here in
Brussels today
that is also the reason for Sweden
holding the current presidency of the
European Union and the EU commission to
arrange this meeting for the people of
turkey and Syria
this conference has one clear goal to
make the struggle of rebuilding everyday
lives and communities easier
we need to make sure the response from
the International Community is strong
efficient and coordinated
the challenge to rebuild cannot be
exaggerated
the affected area in trikia and Syria
equals actually the countries of Belgium
and Netherlands together
whole cities and societies need to be
reconstructive and the survivors will
need to help to return to a slightly
more normal life
we still do not have precise figures on
all the physical destruction
but we're talking about large sums the
total economic impact will be
devastating and long term
however
we know one more thing
that when the EU and the internal
International Community makes a strong
effort together we can make enormous
difference
this was clearly manifested by the large
number of EU countries and other nations
quickly sending search and rescue teams
tents field hospitals generators and
other support to the people affected
from Sweden we quickly sent teams of
experts on immediate relief
I was impressed by the strong will also
of private individuals ngos and the
business Community to help as well
the initial and fast response to the
earthquakes must be followed by solid
support for continued humanitarian
relief recovery Rehabilitation and
reconstruction
my own country Sweden will today pledge
500 million Swedish kroner equivalent to
45 million euros to support humanitarian
reconstruction efforts in turkey and
humanitarian assistance and
Rehabilitation in Syria
this conference
has one clear goal to make the struggle
of rebuilding everyday life's Community
easier
we will Channel our funds through
long-standing Partners the undp the
UNICEF the unhcr and the wfp
this conference provides the EU and The
Wider International Community with an
opportunity to show the affected people
in turkey and Syria that we will stand
by you as you rebuild your everyday
lives
our job here today is to make sure the
EU and The Wider International Community
provide adequate and effective support
to make these challenges easier to face
the solidarity with the people of turkey
and Syria must today be transformed from
words into action this is why we have
invited you all here today thank you so
much
[Applause]
thank you very much prime minister
thank you president
and now it is
our honor to give the floor to his
Excellency the president of Turkey
Mr erdogan
but before he is addressed